having uh an accident everybody
everything's all right but
i wish it was a good story it's
pathetic adam sandler spills the deets
on how he ended up with a black eye the
actor opens up on the tonight show
starring jimmy fallon and explains how
he got himself the shiner while staying
in a hotel room you know when they make
the bed uh and they tuck in the bottom
part of the bed
so i'm in the in the bed and i'm kind of
like it's four in the morning i forgot
to untuck it i'm going why is it so
uncomfortable here i'm feeling squished
and and i have my phone
is here next to me it started getting
panicky and i
kicked my uh legs feel like it's like
that and boom and a phone flies in there
and it hits me in the face
[Music]
yeah seems like adam didn't see that one
coming but word to the wise it really
can happen to anyone
painful painful the actor says it only
got worse from there
i was bleeding terribly
i mean i felt it was pitch black in the
room and i i feel and i feel wetness and
i go yes
i trick myself i go those are probably
just thick tears
because i really was so tired and i was
like ah we'll fix that later so i slept
then i think i took a pillow and put it
on it to stop the bleeding and then when
i woke up i was bleeding all over it was
gushing and still and
i said i got gotta get this fixed so i
went to the apple store
leave it to the 55-year-old comedian to
make light of a really dark situation
adam's injury happened amid the press
tour for his flick hustle
taking me to see basketball or bare
knuckle boxing and this black eye
incident it's not the first in the
actor's recent series of unfortunate
events adam told e.t he injured himself
while shooting hoops on set for the
basketball movie i popped my groin there
was one night my groin my groin couldn't
take it anymore and then i said i guess
i'm gonna have to watch these guys go
hold on you popped your groin you pulled
bad man and i gotta say it's been a year
already and i'm still limping around
like a fool oh it's horrible and it
seems like adam can't catch a break
because he also told jimmy he was
attacked by get this a seagull on a nude
beach in spain i take my bathing suit
off and i'm like staying [ __ ] i
shouldn't do this so there was a spanish
seagull
uh nearby
and the spanish seagull
i think uh
it translated to the word worm
and uh
it starts coming towards me and then one
of the other seasons no no no worm no
worms no no and then but then then a
third here goes mcdonald french fry so
they started coming at me
i gave it to him adam our advice to you
maybe take it easy and lay low for a bit
all right
[Music]
you